the next couple who will dance in the
finale is Alexis and our and that means
June Jenna and Juan Pablo and Cheryl
have been eliminated
I agree
I am so bummed and everybody backstage
here watching had their jaws literally
open were you just as shocked I think we
were so bloody hard to get here and also
to put on a show every Monday and to Wow
maybe that's not what people want to see
but that's what happened I mean you guys
literally got I think I counted five
perfect scores this season two of them
tonight do you think people just thought
you were an automatic shoo-in Sabrina
Brian and Mark Ballas right she laughs
like what week five and she got a
perfect score so you know if that's what
happens it's like it just depends two
people may want to see somebody with two
left feet all of a sudden becomes the
dancer like I don't know I don't know
you know it's different for everybody
but all I know is that the perfect
scores are really nice to see you're
fuller house cast here tonight and I
actually talked to them I talked to Lori
and Jody you were so sad for you what
did they say to you when they were
hugging you well just you know Jodi was
like it sucks it sucks and I know
exactly how you feel but you know what
I'm proud of you so because they're my
family that my second family so what do
you learn most about yourself throughout
this process I think I learned to be a
bit more humble yeah because I've had
two
gave it up so that she could do and
create whatever she wanted to create I'm
uh I'm a control freak myself but this
is her world you know and so I put
myself in her hands and and it's been
quite beautiful actually what's next for
you what will you do tomorrow not having
to go to dance practice I'm gonna get
really fat you have a wedding so I know
in and out by the way how much do you
want to bet we also have a finale we're
gonna have to dance are you ready for
that
oh yeah yes yeah might as well
okay thank you guys so much I'm so
bummed but it was a pleasure seriously
to watch you guys this season incredible
yeah we'll see you guys announced et
also caught up with Juan Pablos fuller
house co-stars who were in the ballroom
cheering him on you guys have a reaction
to him going how am i shocked that he's
going home we can't even believe it how
do you comfort him right now what did
you say to him he's so talented he's
such a good sport and he understands but
honestly it's shocking like how he was
the best dancer in the competition how
is that you heard the crowd when they
announced his name like everybody
hugging him and I just wanted your
reaction and everyone backstage
literally jaws on the floor I mean it's
hard to go out when you've done your
best dance yeah but I yeah but people
you know America what I've learned
watching the show is America doesn't
always vote for the best dancer they
vote for a lot of other reasons since
ones that I don't always get but what I
have to say I'm proud of Keo I was so
torn tonight because I'm like one person
and then somebody else got it to the
place
yeah I know that you to do dance when
the stars previously what kind of advice
or what did you just say to him when you
were hugging I just told him like I said
I I got eliminated the night I got all
tens and did the best thing so I know
how it feels when you like yeah where
and where I am and then you're like wait
what but it's like he had an amazing
experience and I'm so proud of him and I
think all of us are just proud that like
people got to see what he's capable of
and get to know Juan Pablo a little bit
more because we absolutely adore him and
he's so amazingly talented and in other
words he won yeah no you are in our